face à l'invité politique j'ai reçu ce
soir marielle de sarnez députée
européenne et vice-présidente du modem
bonsoir soir conseil européen sommet
européen ce soir à bruxelles on attend
la déclaration de françois hollande un
instant talent il y avait deux urgences
à la grèce et l'ukraine on commence avec
la grèce angela merkel à huis clos avec
alexis tsipras sort et prononcez le mot
de compromis ce soir vous vous dites au
petit millier jeudi qu'elle a raison et
que c'est la seule façon d'avancer est
donc il faut qu'on avance il va falloir
que type race lâche 2,3 points et puis
va falloir que les européens regardent
les choses un peu plus intelligemment
aussi à la vérité on a obligé la grèce à
n'ont pas à faire des réformes depuis
cinq ans par exemple la réforme du
cadastre la réforme de la fiscalité on
les a obligé à couper dans les salaires
on les a obligés à augmenter les impôts
ce qui n'est pas une bonne politique de
long terme donc il faut que de sipera
sofo faut négocier avec lui un agenda de
réformes qui est vraiment des réformes
de fond qui se passe chez lui je note en
passant que tous ceux qui lui demandent
des réformes de fond n'est pas fort les
font pas forcément chez eux donc c'est
pas si simple que ça et on mène la danse
oui bah exemple et en même temps il va
falloir qu'on lâche un peu de lest qu'on
arrête de demander par exemple des
nationalisations de vendre tout de suite
par exemple le saiss qui a été dans le
temps le pire et aux gens du pirée bon
vent à bas prix on brade tout ça n'est
pas ne serait pas sérieux alors après on
peut renégocier la dette dans la durée
faire baisser les taux d'intérêt mais
enfin il va falloir aussi que type race
tienne les engagements de son pays
l'autre évidemment grands dossiers ce
soir c'est l'ukraine avec l'accord de
mines ce qui a été signé ce matin une
nuit entière de négociations
c'est un bon accord d'après vous jetant
à corps en trompe-l'oeil potentiellement
que déjà il fallait agir et françois
hollande et angela merkel ont raison de
tout tenter j'espère que ça va réussir
là aussi avant la fin des compromis il
faut que les ukrainiens fasse des
compromis notamment avec une réforme
constitutionnelle avec peut-être une
fédéralisation plus d'autonomie aux
régions de l'est qui va falloir que
poutine comprennent aussi que c'est une
intégrité territoriale qu'il ne faut
plus menacés donc bien sûr qu'il va
falloir faire des compromis de part et
d'autre mais moi je suis heureuse quand
je vois que les européens les
responsables politiques hommes et femmes
politiques européens s'occupent au fond
de l'avenir de l'europe ne le laisse pas
gérés par d'autres par exemple par les
américains il était temps que les
européens s'y mettent et donc moi je
salue tout à fait leur initiative l'axé
franco allemand c'est important alors
sur la vente des rafale maintenant on
l'a appris ce soir le président l'a
annoncé c'est enfin fait il y aura une
exportation de rafale c'est l'egypte qui
est acheteuse 24 avions en tout votre
réaction c'est bien c'est pas bien
longtemps les exportations françaises on
va dire 1,5 milliard qui j'espère
entreront dans les caisses parce qu'il
faut encore finir le montage financier
avec les égyptiens qui n'ont pas
tellement d'argent donc il va falloir
trouver des prêts relais mais enfin je
suppose que ça va se faire vous avez un
doute sur le fait que les 5 milliards à
rio on sait bien que l'egypte est en
difficulté financière mais je suppose
qu'ils y travaillent alors cet accord
plus la corde minsky l on sait jamais
peut-être ce soir tout à l'heure une
annonce sur la grèce est ce que vous
vous dites là le président roland de
lisbonne séquence là je me dis qu'on les
vit dans un monde très très difficile et
compliqué et qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
beaucoup de bonne nouvelle est que si on
arrive à avoir ce cessez le feu ce
week-end on verra on verra si on arrive
à favoriser faciliter la paix entre
l'ukraine et la russie et a stabilisé
cette partie la
frontière c'est bravo c'est normal c'est
quoi c'est bien il a bien fait son
travail lui et angela merkel quand il
est parti tout de suite après sa
conférence de presse moi je les salue et
j'ai trouvé que c'était une très bonne
initiative de leurs parts au fonds
l'europe elle existe voilà moi vous
savez je suis parlementaire européenne
je crois profondément dans le monde tel
qu'il est il faut une europe forte et
quand on voit l'europe existe et ça me
fait plaisir est ce que cette séquence
irait jusqu'à vous faire dire tiens
pourquoi pas repenser à françois
hollande pour 2017 ou réseau l'espace de
vie de mélanger les choses rsa vous
ennuie pas là on parle de quoi on parle
de l'avenir du monde on parle de
l'avenir de la paix on parle de tous
ceux qui sont morts là bas la frontière
entre l'ukraine et la russie alors si on
pouvait temps en temps mettre les
affaires de politique intérieure
française alors que derrière l'intérêt
général va ce serait vraiment bien on va
en parler séparément si vous voulez bien
parlons donc de politique intérieure
c'est qu'il voulait bien
udry qui présentera un candidat en 2017
a déclaré son président je n'exclus pas
un rapprochement avec le modem et vous
voulez que je trouve tout ce j'aime bien
jean christophe la gamme mais je trouve
ce type de déclarations absolument à
contretemps je dis est ce que c'est la
question de savoir qui va être candidat
à l'élection présidentielle ont fait une
déclaration d'amour envoyées moussa je
suis très contente pour les déclarations
d'amour je prends toujours bien sûr avec
plaisir mais vous voyez bien que la
question c'est la présidentielle c'est
pas un jeu je veux dire c'est pas un jeu
mais il est temps pour le modem de dire
oui les 60 ans à présent vous étiez à
côté de france à olemps et dont vous
êtes où c'est dans deux ans le modem il
est d'un seul côté que la prochaine
élection présidentielle soit un succès
pour le pays est un succès pour le pays
ça veut dire que celui ou celle qui sera
élu puisse gouverner puisse rassembler
et puisse enfin faire les réformes dont
le pays a besoin je vais poser mais sa
balle en obsession je vais poser ma
question différemment si alain juppé
n'était pas le candidat de l'ump on a
bien compris que françois bayrou est
président aime bien alain juppé mais si
alain juppé n'était pas le candidat du
mps que vous pourriez imaginer ce
jour-là rassemblement avec lui des i qui
lui ferait candidature à part moi je
pense qu'il faudra un rassemblement là
je pense que si le front national est
aujourd'hui là où il est il le doit à 30
années au fond de bipartisme et d'une
bipolarisation ump/ps ps ump l'un
l'autre alternativement pouvoir je crois
qu'il faut rompre avec ça donc je crois
qu'il faut des rassemblements larges
nouveau avec des calendriers de réforme
soutenu par une majorité large qui va on
va dire de la droite républicaine à une
gauche sociale démocrate en passant par
le centre ce que j'adore a fait par
exemple en allemagne en s'appuyant sur
les uns et sur les autres c'est ça dans
la france a besoin donc la france elle a
besoin d'hommes et de femmes politiques
qui mettent l'intérêt général avant les
intérêts particuliers qui enfin voilà
s'accordent sur les quelques réformes
importantes pour le pays moi c'est ça
mon c pas l'europe de l'atlantique à
l'oural c'est le sait le rassemblement
l'union nationale de l ça reste
je n'ai pas du tout envie que les
extrêmes un jour l'emportent dans mon
pays et donc j'ai envie qu'une
alternative est donc pour ça
les extrêmes qui la place de
l'opposition le siège d'opposition
officielle à ce que vous appelez les
extrêmes parce que qui dit alliance dit
laissez la place vacante moi j'ai envie
de succès pour mon pays j'ai envie que
ça fonctionne j'ai envie que les
français gagne demain aussi pour eux un
pouvoir d'achat en emploi en croissance
j'ai envie de mon pays se réveille j'en
dis qu'il retrouve de l'énergie je ferai
tout pour ça vous allez nous dire si la
preview ça peut participer au réveil des
énergies à un parti qui parle déjà de
2017 il en rêve il en est pas là pour
l'heure il va se frotter aux urnes pour
la première fois départemental c'est un
parti musulman l'union des démocrates
musulmans de france c'est bien qu'ils
aient un parti musulman qui se constitue
en france écoutez je ne sais pas c'est
pas interdit en tous les cas mais
qu'elle avait à peu près 300 politique
alors on verra mois entre les annonces
et la réalité je suis quelqu'un qui aime
bien des jets pour voir moi c'est pas
mon idée de la politique on idée de la
politique n est pas confessionnel elle
n'est pas communautaire elle est on va
dire républicaine et votre et des
l'université la question se repose un
enseignant paris 13 a été suspendu pour
avoir interdit de courir étudiants volé
ce qu'ils n'avaient pas le droit de
faire est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas dû le
faire parce qu'ils n'en avaient pas
droit ou est-ce qu'il faut les faire
évoluer la loi et faire comme dans les
collèges les écoles les lycées
éventuellement étant de la loi sur la
laïcité l'université les universités
sont autonomes il faut qu'elles gèrent
ce type de problème aussi elle même bon
je pense qu'on a une loi qui est
d'application qui se passe bien au
collège et au lycée est ce qu'on va
réouvrir encore aujourd'hui un débat sur
l'université j'y suis pas favorable
merci marie est revenue répondant aux
questions vous restez avec nous on va
reprendre cette image en direct venu
répondre à nos questions